there was a completely bizarre dystopian
rally over the weekend in illinois this
was a rally in support supposedly of
illinois republican mary miller now mary
miller once praised adolf hitler we'll
get to that
donald trump spoke at this rally donald
trump was completely incoherent he
looked disoriented he struggled to speak
even in repeating some of the same lines
we've become used to ad nauseam from
trump he was visibly struggling to
deliver deliver them so first i'll give
you a reminder mary miller the rally was
in support of mary miller here is older
footage of mary miller who said hey you
know hitler was right about one thing
each generation has the responsibility
to teach
in the next generation you know if we
win a few elections we're still going to
be losing unless we win the hearts
of our children
this it's the battle
hitler was right on one thing he said
whoever has a youth has the future
our children are being propagandized
yeah and you know if you want to make
the case that the youngest generation is
going to decide what the future looks
like you can find people other than
hitler who have made similar points so
choosing to quote hitler and say that
this is this hitler knew this pretty
wacky stuff so this is who trump went to
illinois to support that's who he was
there to support
maybe the most bizarre moment of trump's
speech trump mimicking weightlifting
during the
anti-transgender part of the rally
there's always an anti-trans part of the
rally now
there you go so that's trump uh
yeah
um this is now a regular part of every
rally trump saying teachers should not
be allowed to teach transgender very
strange grammatical syntax
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender to our children that
way derby and you ready
never ever teach transgender to our
children
um
i don't know exactly what he means
teachers shouldn't be allowed to
mention that trans people exist what
does that even really mean
but completely mushmouth and unable to
deliver
these uh these diatribes um at a certain
point trump endorsed this is so funny
endorsed mary miller
i don't know that i've ever heard a less
enthusiastic endorsement he's sort of
like yeah you know vote for her she'll
be good go out and vote for mary you'll
never be disappointed with mary she
doesn't disappoint
people and she loves you very much yeah
you can really tell trump is viscerally
committed to supporting uh mary miller
there yeah yeah yeah go and go and vote
for her and then donald trump is now
claiming that the january 6 trump riot
committee
is using doctored video
doctored video to make their points now
i have to tell you
if the argument you're relegated to is
the videos were doctored
the testimony was probably pretty damn
effective take a look at this to this
day the leaders of the democrat party
have failed to forcefully condemn the
violence and threats and hold
the perpetrators accountable
there could be no greater illustration
of the two-tiered system of justice
we've never had anything like what's
going on right now that we have in our
country than the fact that
at the very moment the radical democrats
were staging a ridiculous fake trial
over january 6. their party leaders are
saying nothing about the violent
intimidation of the united states
supreme court they refused to talk about
it they refused to do anything
as you have seen the vile group of
unhinged partisans and craven lunatics
on the unselect committee are pushing a
fake and fabricated narrative based on
doctored video lies and tests by the way
i hate to interrupt but just the toe so
trump is lying to the crowd
there are the blacks for trump people
are up on the stage strategically placed
behind trump
and the channel broadcasting the speech
right side broadcasting is offering a
free gold
coin if you text trump
it's i mean it it's grift upon lie upon
grift upon lie testimony that is totally
uncontested by cross-examination the
lies are unbelievable
it's a disgrace to our country
a bunch of rhinos get up they're going
to make their name big for a day
everything they're showing is ripped
utterly out of context such as when liz
cheney a real loser she is cut out
cut out the part of my quote in a speech
that i made a certain speech
that said
that their voices should be heard
peacefully and patriotically she left
those words out would you say that's
nice she left them out
it's a sham think of that she left out
the words peacefully and patriotically
why aren't they investigating massive
election fraud and irregularities
instead of investigating because it
doesn't exist the people who want to get
to the bottom of a rigged and stolen
election
all right
so you get the point there and there
seems to be a growing sensation within
trumpland
that the hearings were much more
effective than they imagined they would
be and this is why they're now relegated
to saying the video is doctored the
video is doctored that's what it is
the uh news story from trump and it's
not new but trump is now regularly
talking about it is
nancy pelosi
allowed the riots to get out of control
trump has said this a few times before
but now he's really piling on
and why didn't nancy pelosi and the
mayor of washington dc
accept my offer on january 3rd three
days before
of 10 000 soldiers or national guard or
more
to protect the capital you know they are
in charge of security now that is untrue
this has been repeated many times it's
not true first of all there's no
evidence trump made any request to
deploy ten thousand national guard
troops before the rally trump it's been
claimed there's no evidence of that
whatsoever number one secondly nancy
pelosi is not in charge the capitol
police are in charge the capitol police
are overseen by the capitol police board
and committees from the senate and from
the house it is not nancy pelosi that is
in charge so that's a lie
trump also taking the opportunity to
mention that you should sign up for his
um platform truth social truth essential
yeah and saying there's no free speech
anymore but sign up for truth we don't
have
free speech in america yeah
go out and sign up now for truth social
who's on truth social doing good very
muted response there um truth social
will ban you if you post clips from the
january 6th committee hearing so not
exactly the unfettered bastion of free
speech that donald trump claims it to be
and then lastly not very patriotic trump
saying america is no longer a great
nation these illinois heroes poor are
incredible they just went out and they
poured
their heart and soul to make america
into the greatest nation in the history
of the world they worked to make america
the greatest nation
in the history of the world
but
it is no longer a great nation it is a
nation
in decline
wow
no longer a great nation and of course i
thought the patriots always would say
america is always great it's always the
best i guess now maybe
an s-hole country might be better i
guess because joe biden is president so
everything going wrong trump completely
incoherent and supporting someone
with no enthusiasm whatsoever
who once explained that hitler was right
about one thing that is the modern state
of trumpism and the crowd just eats it
all up he could tell him anything and
they would clap and they would cheer
we'll have these clips on our instagram
you can find them at david pakman show
we'll take a break after the break we're
going to hear from some trump supporters
at the rally and my recommendation would
be get the children out of the room
i think this is the biggest discount
that any sponsor has ever offered on the
david pakman show this is crush organics
crush organics loves the show so much
they're giving my viewers 50 off their
entire collection of organic cbd
products when you use the code pacman
i'm the only show
where you can get this big a discount
that i like and for each sale crush
organics will donate ten dollars to the
last prisoner project that's a really
great non-profit helps to
free non-violent drug offenders and
reform drug laws very important and it
doesn't stop there anyone who uses my
code also gets a free jar
of cbd gummies or a jar of cbd topical
cream crush has only the best organic
cbd whether you're looking for oils
creams or edibles so that's 50 off and a
free jar of gummies or topical cream and
10 bucks towards creating real change in
our justice system go to crush organics
dot u s
and use the code pacman the link is down
below